I would pretend that I bracers I would
put them on like there may be like ma my
breath is so cool alright y'all it's
officially holy season and what this
means people is yes it's true it's candy
time and since I'm a foodie shocker I
know I'm gonna test out some candy I'm
gonna rate some Halloween candy best to
worst that's right I'm gonna offend a
lot of people I don't care that's my
opinion
but really it's the correct opinion okay
there you go
[Music]
yeah let's get started we're gonna start
with good and plenty which I've never
even seen in my life what this is a
cotton candy well let's open it let's
try it good and plenty good & plenty
looks like a giant Tic Tac hmm oh yeah
it's licorice I hate like this that's
gonna stay right there good and plenty
to keep a bit love licorice you're gonna
want to get into this people that don't
mmm this is the bad side sorry good &
plenty I'm just another licorice fan but
for all of you that are Bravo continue I
mean here's the thing I don't need to
taste test this one cuz we go way back
that's so good that caramel nougat yummy
nice this is not standing
oh I love this bucket Risa Scott it's so
interesting I've never tried one of
these so I guess I will
well I guess some are gonna one more Bob
why is it bad for you it's so good that
is definitely awesome this is the
awesome side
candy corn how I eat candy corn is each
color at a time
since I was a child take white we go
take the orange and then you went and
save the best for last
oh my god candy corn sheller why are you
shaking her head white what I bet you
like licorice see we can't hang with
candy corn controversial why it is not
disgusting weiss here's the thing about
butterfingers see this isn't fair I
worked at a movie theater that was my
first job so all this junk was hanging
out there but here's the thing about
butterfingers they're awesome that they
stay stuck in your teeth for days I will
brush and like first I love a butter for
your book I'm gonna put in the middle
because here's the thing
it's not good or bad it's just like
still there in my molar like right now
I'm just gonna hold on to it what if I
got this in my basket as the kids the
trick or treater I'll be like take this
outta my best is it good a swedish fish
no kid wants to be like me fish thanks
is it it's a little gummy
[Music]
no no no sir twice I say no to you
we can never go trick-or-treating
together or we can and then you take the
candy I hate and I think candy you hate
how that works out
I mean M&Ms are you for real right now
ice you know like Eminem's like the most
basic candies so good
none of your skittles van my husband
okay you might as good holes oh my go
ahead so opposite we're never gonna get
married why it's over skittles are good
I'll put a link right on the other side
of but it's just weird I don't know what
it is like what is it do you know I'm
saying what is a skittle it's not a
rainbow I trust nothing when it doesn't
put what's in it on it that's nothing my
husband does love those oh whoops sorry
taste the rainbow in that that one good
marketing
I don't think I've ever had a mound but
I mean chocolate and coconut I'm in it's
like a party hell yeah
whoa mounds are good dark chocolate and
coconut dark chocolate that's healthy
right it's not the milk chocolates a
little better right Twizzlers
you know what I used to do cuz I worked
in movie theaters my first job I used to
get a coke and then I'd cut I didn't
really like plain coke oh this one would
just work what it's already a straw but
they aren't like that aside to off the
ends and then I just ii have a little
sherry coca strawberry coke I love it
and I would pretend that I braces well I
did actually get braces but before that
I would put them on my girth mom my
braces so cool Twizzlers I would
definitely say are down on this the
party this little area
I don't do 2-0 I'd get why people like
to throw us but I like the ones they
have these ones in they've like a
vanilla
well that closer is just hanging out
with that butter finger and just camping
out when I was gonna like a Butterfinger
with a twizzler
not hating on it I don't really do
Twizzlers but I'd say it's better than
that okay cat good kappa gimme a break
gimme a break I know all these tag lines
how bad is that
okay these are great watch you know I'm
gonna be able to get on what the hell
this is either well you know it's
chocolate but like what is it is it like
a wafer wafer really good I'm gonna barf
if I agent even more candy I gotta put
this here KitKat KitKat going this fun
little party
the ultimate winner honestly shocking
but vo good old Mound
I'd never had fun facts I went to an
elementary school called Mound
Elementary it's not really a fun fact
for you you're like that's useless
knowledge that will never be useful in
my life but just hit me just came in my
head so I just you know what I gave it
to gets a gift you're welcome
Mound wins the ultimate worst one is
absolutely 110 percent this licorice
nonsense down here and this has been
check or treat by Casey I hope you enjoy
it hope you have a good trick-or-treat
night check your candy freaks are out
there okay maybe buy your own candy just
let your kids walk around and get them
and then be like yeah and this is the
candy cuz you never know date one exists
for a reason there's a lot of them out
there apparently stay woke I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this